Beth from Skye can we take you first I
can see you've arrived safely just about
got here
kirst armor at a time when people are
struggling to pay their bills feed their
families in a striking overpay
settlements you've produced a
155-page report talking about Devolution
constitutional reform and abolishing the
House of Lords this might look to many
people as completely out of touch and
you could look like another politician
talking to Westminster about stuff that
might never come to pass can you give me
one thing in this report that would
improve people's lives from day one of a
labor government and if I made to Gordon
Brown
Nicholas sturgeon has declared the next
election of de facto Independence
referendum you talk about further
Devolution but hasn't the horse already
bolted and and do you accept that
Scotland could become an independent
nation in your lifetime or mine thank
you Beth the complete opposite of the
proposition you put to me this is
vitally important if we ask ourselves in
this room across the country what is the
single biggest thing that's holding us
back it's failure of economic growth
over the last 12 years I profoundly
believe that amongst the causes for that
is because we have not allowed and
empowered every part of our country to
play its part in building our economy
we've allowed we've relied far too much
on London and the southeast we have not
let the whole country play its part this
addresses that question and I can tell
you wherever I am across the country
whether it's Burnley whole blackball
Sterling Sunderland Southampton
everybody I meet and so did my shadow
cabinet they meet communities and
businesses and people that say we've got
ideas we've got Innovation we want our
community and our place to be be even
better than it is we just need a
government that shares our ambition
shares our vision for the future so this
could not be more relevant and you know
I'm fed up to the back teeth with
sticking plasters for the problems that
we've got the underlying problem is our
economy isn't working this is a strong
compelling set of recommendations that
do what politicians have all agreed
needs to be done but nobody's actually
done it which is to be bold enough to
say that we've got to stop those in
Westminster and Whitehall pretending
that they know best about the
communities that desperately want to
play their part in the future we're
going to transfer that power to them
rebuild our economy and I don't think
this is the complete opposite of a
discussion in Westminster it's accepting
that Westminster is not the place for
those decisions to be made they've got
to be made elsewhere Gordon can I bring
you in on the second element of that
just as in 2016 a lot of people voted
for brexit because they thought that was
their only chance of change
in 2014 a lot of people voted for
Independence because they thought that
was the only change on offer we are
changing that entirely today we are
breaking new ground the ground on which
the battle is fought in Scotland is
changing forever because what we are
saying is we are offering change within
the UK that will benefit Scotland as
against change by leaving the United
Kingdom which we think will do damage to
Scotland and that's going to be the
debate from now on in not change and not
Independence versus the status quo but
change within Britain versus change by
leaving Britain and the measures of
course we're putting forward to give
more power to Scotland and to Wales and
to the regions and localities and
communities of England all go hand in
hand and are in the same direction
together
so when you come to the next election it
may be that the Scottish national party
will have a one-line Manifesto and want
a one-issue general election but I tell
you this we have done a huge amount of
research on Scottish public opinion and
people want a Better Health Service
immediately people want living standards
improved immediately people want jobs
for young people immediately people want
better housing immediately and people of
course want change in the way that we
are suggesting immediately and that's
going to be the issue in which we're
fought we fight we are offering a plan
for economic social political and
constitutional reform not a one-issue
election thank you
Mr storm so just if I may be a bit
cheeky and ask us a quick follow-up I
asked you one which policy in this
report from day one will change people's
lives because it's so amorphous what's
the one thing that you're gonna do the
most important thing in that report that
will change all of our Lives power in
relation to skills education transport
resources finances into our local
communities so that they can help us
grow the economy there are so many
examples of this you've got video games
in Dundee you've got Ceramics in the
Midlands you've got Creative Media in
Bristol and bath
hydrogen could be what the Northeast
revitalizes around there are so many
examples I think we've got 288 economic
clusters if we were able to transfer
power in this way and get those clusters
to operate it will bring about a huge
change everywhere including here in
Leeds that would if we were to turn
around our economy will begin to turn
around our economy we have a massive all
these issues about the cost of living
and the strikes all the things you ask
us every day have one common cause and
that is our economy is not working for
everyone in this country it is the
mission of the next Labor government not
only to fight the election on that issue
to win it and to bring about the change
that we desperately desperately need in
this country